it would be an utmost sign of weakness
and a failure of leadership if he allows
Trump to be arrested also within his
speech that he's talking about uh you
know not getting involved he's saying
that it's political persecution
okay so if you're saying it and you're
admitting to it but you're also at the
same time saying you're not going to do
anything about it this is how you be a
leader like you're saying exactly the
other supporters happy like Jeb Bush you
know right Bush would like this rhetoric
from DeSantis yes that's why he has Jeb
Bush in his corner it's not even for
sure it's it's it's already bad enough
DeSantis wasn't strong enough in his in
his statement saying I'm not going to
get involved in any way is already bad
enough if he actually lets Trump be
extraded so here's what needs to happen
DeSantis if he wants to prove he's
presidential he says Donald Trump he
needs to come out and say Donald Trump
will not be extradited from this state
under my watch for a political
persecution he is the front-runner for
the Republican party's 2024 presidential
run